people would say that this thing thing
doesn't really matter that much as I'm
sure in the last I mean we got away yeah
we've got to get a win and we got to
play well simple as that I mean yeah
corner of the playoffs and all that it
doesn't I guess but we want to give
ourself a chance to win and to win as we
finish the season out and to win in the
and that tournament as you get there you
got to get momentum going dak Prescott
talking about the importance of the
Cowboys winning a game they've lost
three in a row and here come the red-hot
LA Rams to try to make it even harder
for the Cowboys to get to the postseason
Cowboys have lost seven of the last ten
they started three and oh they're three
and seven since then here come the Rams
turning it around after that but I give
him a lot of credit they got blown off
the field by the Ravens they have been
great since then they're very dangerous
I think they're gonna go into Dallas and
win and the Cowboys can lose this one
and still win their last two and win the
division it all comes down to Dallas at
Philadelphia for the NFC East I believe
so they really don't need this one as
badly as we would think all the more
reason to think the Rams who desperately
need it will go into Dallas and win I
agree with you there I think the Rams
have figured it out a little bit I also
think Todd Gurley looks like you know
healthy old Todd Gurley the way he's
running he's running really hard the
Cowboys and Eagles these two teams we do
this every year in the NFL where we say
you know I called it the Falcons
syndrome a couple years ago where you're
waiting for their best game they have
all this talent you're waiting for their
best game maybe they just stink and
maybe that's what the Cowboys are maybe
their best game is not coming because
that's just the team they are not a good
one yeah you know that occurred to me
last Thursday night watching them lose
to the Bears we assumed that the
coaching is the problem with the Cowboys
they may just not be very good and this
is my one critique of Jerry Jones who
has assembled a collection of highly
talented players how much consideration
was given to how those players are going
to come together how they're gonna mesh
how they're going to become a team
because it hasn't worked
it started off well because they played
a crap schedule and then it got more
difficult and now we've seen this free
fall and I don't think they're gonna be
able to hang with the Rams but again it
all comes down I believe to next week at
Philadelphia one of those teams is going
to earn the NFC East championship and
the home play
game that goes along with it as unfair
as that may be Vikings charges and you
know big cat I had to take at one point
the Vikings are going to be seven and
seven after 14 games and they're gonna
have to beat the Packers and the Bears
to get to the playoffs I was wrong about
their record they're now nine and four
which is good but now they have to beat
the Chargers the Packers and the Bears
to get to the playoffs it's all on Kirk
Cousins can he deliver with the season
on line because the Rams are coming up
strong from the outside they need to go
to LA and beat the Chargers who even
though they were five and eight are very
dangerous and they could rise up and win
this game in that twenty seven thousand
seat high school football stadium they
play their games in well you the
Chargers are dangerous the Chargers are
one of those teams I feel like we say
this about the Chargers every single
year that they're not in the playoff
race that they look like a playoff team
if they had just found a way to win a
couple of those one score games where
Phil Rivers is down in the fourth
quarter Mike a little stat for you I
brought a little stat the Chargers are
35% 35% win rate at home since 2014 they
don't win at home they win it on the
road they don't win at home there's no
home advantage here the Vikings will go
and win this game as much as I don't
want them to they will go and win this
game yeah I'm I just I want to see what
Kirk Cousins can do when we get to that
point in the year where everything
starts to tighten up and you understand
these are big moments these are big
games he's a big drives he's a big
throws now I think Vikings fans will
overrun that Stadium they'll be doing
the Skoll clap all day long and the
charges are used to I think that's one
of the reasons why they're so good on
the road they never have a home-field
advantage
they're used they'd rather they'd rather
go on the road and be the outcast than
be the outcasts in their own home so but
but still this is on the Vikings the
Vikings have to seize this they were not
impressive last week against the Lions
yes they did enough to win the game it
just wasn't the kind of showing you
expect from a team that should be in the
mix for something significant in the NFC
because I think they are a good team
let's see if they can deliver that's the
real question one more crazy stat with
the Chargers their plus 38 point
differential the 10 and 3 Seattle
Seahawks are plus 20 point differential
so it's it's crazy
now this league works if you win your
close games you win your one score games
find a way to win those coin flip games
your season can look totally different
the Green Bay Packers also ten and three
are plus 39 so basically identical win
point margins point differential and
that's the Chargers way that's how the
Chargers kind of always are that's how
they were last year Phillip Rivers said
after the season that they could have
been 16 and O or six and ten last year
because every game was a close game and
they ended up winning twelve of them
they're not winning them this year or
they would be in the mix in the AFC
Eagles at Washington Philly can win the
division if they just win their last
three now when you've only won 6 out of
13 there's not a whole lot of confidence
you're gonna win the last three but they
have Washington the Cowboys in the
Johnson once again it's going to come
down to what happens week 16 I think
it's more important for the Eagles to
win this week though you don't want to
be a game behind the Cowboys going into
that that week 16 game I think you want
to at least be even or a game ahead of
them even so it's gonna come down to
week 16 I think something woke up for
the Eagles in the second half of that
Monday night game something clicked for
Carson Wentz he got it done with a bunch
of guys that nobody's ever heard of
playing around and they almost had Josh
McCown playing receiver that's how
banged up they were I think Wentz has it
has arrived at a point almost like true
Biscay it's fixed the confidence is back
he feels like he can get it done and I
think they will get it done this week
and I kind of think they'll get it done
next week - I don't wanna get ahead of
myself for this week I think they'll get
it done at Washington I don't know about
something you know fixing or waking up I
think they just realized they were
playing the New York Giants defense and
it's one of the worst defenses in the
entire NFL I like the Eagles here to win
because I just you know they got
something to play for and the Redskins
well they've had a nice little
resurgence here and they've they have
some talented players and they've shown
a little fight now we're getting into
the 15 16 17 weeks and it's it's a
little tougher to get up when the
season's over and and you're trying to
go tackle someone and get in front of
someone so I think the Eagles will win
this game yeah I agree with you on that
one Seattle Seahawks go to Carolina to
take on the Panthers once upon a time
this had the potential to be a great NFC
rivalry Cam Newton Russel Wilson now
it's Kyle Allen that
Panthers in freefall for the second
straight year they were six into last
year at fell apart this year five and
three it's falling apart they're now
five and eight and the Seahawks need
this one they've got to stay in the mix
for that possible one seed or two seed
in the NFC after losing to the Rams
I think the Seahawks are good enough to
get this back together it would be it
would be almost like a disqualifying
loss if you lose to Carolina a Panthers
team that's in disarray right now
interim coach you have Dante Jackson
cornerback on the Panthers calling out
the head coach for some of the things
they did last week against Atlanta if
you can't beat this team you don't
deserve to be in a position to take the
NFC West from the 49ers I think the
Seahawks win I agree with you there
the Panthers don't really do anything
anymore that scares you their best
player is Christian McCaffrey and he is
phenomenal but he plays the least
valuable position on the football field
at running back so they don't do
anything that I think will will will
give the Seahawks fits here the only way
you could take the Panthers is if you
just convince yourself the Seahawks
can't play on the East Coast which I
don't even know the numbers behind it
that feels like something they had
struggled with in the past and you know
Russell Wilson was the MVP favorite
therefore a little window in time and
Lamar Jackson is kind of taking that
away from him I don't know that that
puts a chip on his shoulder or anything
he just wants to win football games they
had a bad performance on Sunday Night
Football they had been showing up in
prime time and they've been looking good
and Pete Carroll will talk them through
you know they you're gonna lose games
from time to time it happens let's get
it together and let's get moving they
need to get themselves ready though for
what's coming week 17 Seahawks hosting
the 49ers if the Seahawks can hold up
their end of the bargain that game is
going to determine the 1 seed versus the
five seed quite possibly in the NFC and
speaking of the 49ers they host the
Atlanta Falcons a trap game for the 40 -
at home against the 49 Falcons oh yeah
big time trap game before the 49ers
spent two weeks straight on the East
Coast you know they remember they spent
the week between the Ravens loss and the
Saints win in the Panhandle in Florida
practicing out there so they just got
home they have an emotional win in the
dome against the Saints they're riding
high the Falcons are coming in they
stink this is out
lutely a trap game i think this is a
game that you got to take the falcons
+11 any and I do think the foreigners
will win but they're little banged up
and it's hard to get up every single
week for an inferior opponent when you
know you have those big games coming up
week 16 and 17 to basically decide where
your seating is going to be in the NFC
playoffs see I disagree with you on this
and there's one big reason why because I
think Kyle Shanahan is a master of
sticking it to his former teams and he's
got every reason to be a little salty
about the way things ended in Atlanta
because on the way out the door he got
blamed for the 28 to 3 meltdown
specifically the play calling on the
drive where the Falcons could have gone
up 10 points against the Patriots in
Super Bowl 51 the passing instead of the
running so much for the head coach
having the ability to overrule the play
call from the coordinator so much for
the quarterback being the last-ditch
opportunity to avoid disaster by calling
an audible but I think Shanahan and he's
very good at identifying reasons to hold
a grudge and sometimes there are reasons
to hold a grudge we saw it against
Washington we saw it against Cleveland I
think we're gonna see it against the
Falcons if it was any other 4 & 9 5 & 8
team I'd worry about the 49ers here I'm
not worried about the 49ers taking care
of business against the Falcons and
because it's the Falcons and and I also
think that you know they're in that kind
of special season mindset where they're
not going to let their guard down
against anyone especially with the Rams
coming and the Seahawks behind that so I
think the 49ers gonna win I think
they're gonna cover in that okay okay
alright we'll see well maybe well maybe
we'll make a bet on it for for dinner at
the Super Bowl okay I'm sure there's
McDonald's all over South Beach so I'll
take Kerry down there I know that every
restaurant you know what in every game
plan you always access the situation to
see exactly what needs to be done now
the good thing is is that we have some
plays that were build it and I can help
Pat execute things and we needed to get
done but that's something that we have
built in each and every week and we sit
and discuss it all the time you know
there's always a contingency plan
for what if the last thing you want to
do is get caught you know you're not
prepared for certain moments but there's
always a plan lined up Eric the enemy
the offensive coordinator of the Kansas
City Chiefs talking about the
possibility the Patrick mahomes may have
issues he's got the bruised hand look he
missed a couple of games earlier this
year Matt Moore played well I mean
that's plan B put in Matt Moore and Matt
Moore we'll get it done potentially
against the Denver Broncos but you know
what the Broncos all of a sudden aren't
the pushovers that they were after what
they did to the Texans last weekend and
drew Locke drew drew Locke is a guy who
may solve a lot of the problems in
Denver John Elway just kind of flailing
around like a kid trying to whack a
pinata at a birthday party and he's the
pinata is 10 feet away from him and he's
trying to find his quarterback and
finally he's gotten that stick on the
pinata and he's got a quarterback who
can play Andrew Luck I'm excited for the
Broncos it's kind of that same vibe the
Bears have different circumstances but
the idea that there's hope for next year
drew Locke is giving them that hope drew
Locke back in Missouri to play the
Kansas City Chiefs and has a chance to
run his career record to three and oh I
don't think they're gonna pull it off
but I'll tell you what that games a lot
more interesting than it would have been
with Brandon Allen or Joe Flacco under
center for the Broncos I absolutely
agree with that drew Locke I think he
was it was the first time ever a
quarterback has won their first start on
the road throwing 300-plus yards and
three TDs so if he's making history he's
making history it is funny that this
might be the guy John Elway after Miss
Mick's missing on Paxton Lynch after
bringing in Joe Flacco and having
everyone say is he ever going to find a
quarterback if it is drew Locke I like
this game I think it's gonna be
interesting to watch I'll take the
Chiefs but yeah it's it you're right
you're out you nailed it this game now
becomes a lot more fun to watch because
of the presence of Drew Locke and
another great game and a great race to
the finish in the AFC South between the
Houston Texans and the Tennessee Titans
they will play twice over the final
three weeks of the season and the Titans
have now caught the Texans at eight and
five and the Titans are the team you
definitely don't want to mess with right
now big hat they're six and one Ryan's
Hanan Hill has been spectacular Derrick
Henry he's banged up the Derrick Henry
if he's healthy he can get it done as
well all of a sudden it's it's like that
the Texans are this pendulum that swings
so sharply back and forth they get blown
out by the Ravens you have no faith and
they beat the Colts he beat the Patriots
hey they're doing great then they lose
in ugly fashion to the Broncos and I
think they're in real trouble here when
they go to Nashville the former Houston
Oilers taking on the former or the
current rather Houston Texans I believe
in the Titans in this one and I think
the Titans are gonna end up winning the
division oh okay I think I do I do agree
that they're in trouble in this game the
Texans that is I just love this game
because I think it's gonna be points all
over the place I don't I don't trust the
Texans defense the Titans secondary is
banged up both quarterbacks are playing
great I think there's gonna be points
points points in this game and I'd
probably lean towards the Titans at home
with you know the Mojo they have going
and how they felt in the last few weeks
Ryan Tannehill it's incredible Mike I
don't know what do you do
how many years do you give how many
millions do you give Ryan Tannehill do
you franchise them I don't you may have
to franchise them the question is who
else out there is gonna be dangling big
money in his direction I think other
teams are gonna be a little hesitant
that they're gonna think it's not gonna
work for us maybe work for them and you
know injury is something that you have
to worry about if you're Ryan Tannehill
he had the torn ACL before is that other
injury issues so far so good in
Tennessee but I think the Titans find a
way to keep him around maybe a shorter
term deal a two or three-year deal I'm
not I'm not really sure it a lot of it
depends upon what he wants he's been
through a lot of crap in his career he
told me a couple of weeks ago he's
cherishing everything about this phase
of his career because it looked like it
was over for him
and now it's back and it's better than
it's ever been and I think the Titans
ultimately found a way to keep him the
idea the franchise tag to me is is it
seems like a stretch but hey they may
have to do it if they get the sense that
other teams are serious about making a
run at him in the offseason
all right Patriots Bengals a game that
got slightly more interesting thanks to
Spygate - I think that Bill Belichick
will want the curb stop Zack Taylor in
the Bengals I'm anxious to see their
postgame interaction during the game I
think it's gonna be all Patriots and I'm
even more convinced it's gonna be all
Patriots because of the fact that you
got a lot of salty people in that locker
room Oh
this this made up in their mind
controversy regarding the videotaping of
the Bengal sidelines by a member of the
video crew unrelated to the football
department last week when the Bengals
were in Cleveland yeah I think this is a
get right game for the Patriots offense
the Bengals defense doesn't really do
anything special you can run on them you
could pass on them the Patriots it feels
like it will come out of this game
having a little momentum on the
offensive side of the ball putting
together four quarters scoring you know
we're at whatever 28 plus so I think the
Patriots will handle the Bengals easily
in this game yeah I think so too and
I'll tell you what yesterday we were
doing our joint picks podcast Sims and I
we were going back and forth trying we
do our best bets every week and and I
was thinking Patriots to cover or 49ers
to cover I automate Niners to cover
because I just don't trust the Patriots
offense yet I need to see I need bad bet
that's a bad bet on the 49ers I can't
wait for that for that Wendy's that
we're gonna go to oh yeah
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports